[Musique]
le théâtre de plein air de saint-gilles
est implanté dans un lieu où j'ai
beaucoup de souvenirs d'abord de mon
enfance avant sa construction même
puisque ce coin que je fréquentais quand
je venais dans les environs pour dix ont
passé du temps un terrain de jeu plus
qu'une aide vraiment à ma grand mère et
à ma tante dans leur jardin qui est un
potager en fait
et puis on n'allait pas au spectacle
dans les années 70 il a commencé à avoir
quelques fils projections de films en
plein air autour du village artisanal de
maintenant il y avait une plante là mais
sinon la musique elle-même tout ce qu'on
va entendre principalement théâtre de
saint-gilles n'était connue du porno que
dans l'est
à l'occasion par mois des baptêmes les
plus souvent des mariages
animé par l'orchestré caf mais là c'est
icaf coup taille c'est lors qu'elles
sont en cuivre à l'équivalent en dehors
de la sans fil qui nous faisait
découvrir un peu le spectacle on
n'allait pas spectacle et nous on
découvre ça on passe de cela comme ça
comme salle de spectacle alves à la
mariage à ce théâtre magnifique c'est
vraiment un bon en avant extraordinaire
donc donc sa marque l'imaginaire que
j'avais des enfants
c'est le début de la
départementalisation mon analyse c'est
plus pour aujourd'hui que par rapport au
passé c'est à dire moi je découvre une
structure merveilleuse pour moi mais
toujours est il que quand on relit la
départementalisation et plus pourquoi la
demande pas départementalisation puisque
aimé césaire dit lui même il emploie le
mot le mot d'assimilation on voulait
être assimilée comme les autres
départements les autres morceaux ont
volé avant notre part du gâteau ce sont
les mots propres de d'aimé césaire et
cette perte d'assimiliation va se
comprendre de la manière suivante c'est
que debré quand il arrive à la fin des
années 50 des années 60
lui il veut assimiler la réunion comme
un département à tous points de vue
et ce sera l'idée qu'on pourra
construire comme en france les
les grands bâtiments nécessaires pour
traiter de la santé des enfants les
écoles aussi on va passer la période de
massification qui aura lieu réellement
dix ans après la bête la
départementalisation acl c'est à dire la
fin des années 50
là on construit beaucoup d'écoles de ce
côté là et on va donner une culture
forcément métropolitaine au peuple
réunionnais qui est un peuple français
donc il faut trouver quelque chose qui
là où on pourra montrer l'élite
si on peut dire de la culture française
les grandes les grands groupes etc
et donc c'est vrai dans cet état
d'esprit là le début de la
départementalisation
la revendication pour quelque chose de
plus local va démarrer dans les années
[Musique]